dire que nous souhaitons vider les
prisons dire que c'est madame taubira
qui souhaitent ville et des prisons n'a
aucun sens c'est un mensonge
et cela ne fait pas avancer le débat
d'un instant derrière cet amendement se
cassent la possibilité de ne plus
envoyer en prison
ce projet de loi s'il devait être
adoptée aura pour conséquence de
déconstruire le système répressif
d'aggraver le niveau de la délinquance
et au final de mettre gravement en
danger la sécurité nos concitoyens la
droite crient au laxisme mais pour la
gauche la prison a échoué à diminuer la
récidive
il faut créer une peine en dehors du
milieu carcéral ça sera la contrainte
pénale mesure phare de la réforme de
christiane taubira
il s'agit d'une peine au milieu ouvert
qui s'ajoute à l'arsenal répressif
actuelle c'est donc une une peine de
grandes contraintes mais qui ne
désocialise pas et donc qui va est
contestable mans comme on l'a constaté
dans les pays qui pratiquent déjà cette
peine va contribuer sérieusement
significativement à réduire les risques
de récidive la contrainte pénal une
alternative à la prison est une petite
révolution des mentalités mais surtout
pour les socialistes une solution
efficace contre la récidive subir
pendant plusieurs mois puis en année les
obligations fortes mais c'est aussi
contraignant prix de passer
tranquillement en prison
retour en 2012 en pleine campagne
présidentielle françois hollande promet
la rupture avec les années sarkozy
la fin du tout répressif pour lutter
contre la récidive dès septembre
christiane taubira choisi la
concertation de nombreuses personnalités
travail plusieurs mois sur la récidive
leurs conclusions la prison ne doit plus
être la seule réponse à la délinquance
cette question de la centralité de la
peine de prison qui est une invention
des dix neuvième siècle soyons clairs sa
centralité de la peine de prison et bien
aujourd'hui au quatrième siècle
il faut en sortir et la peine de prison
peut-être une peine parmi d'autres
développer les alternatives à la prison
cette conclusion ne fait pas consensus
au gouvernement de lignes s'opposent une
incarné par manuel valls a plus
répressives l'autre incarné par
christiane taubira
mais officiellement tout va bien entre
les deux ministres si nous avons des
désaccords nous parlent haut et nous les
réglons elle comme moi nous voulons
éviter de retomber dans l'opposition
classique et mortifère d'ailleurs pour
nos institutions entre le ministre de
l'intérieur et la garde des sceaux
mais la presse fait des révélations
manuel valls a écrit à françois hollande
et lui demande de renoncer à la réforme
la garde des sceaux réplique c'est la
guerre par courrier interposé
la quasi totalité des dispositions de ce
texte a fait l'objet de discussions
voire d'opposition du ministère de
l'intérieur
les chiffres qui ont été fournis par le
ministère de l'intérieur sont erronés et
leur présentation et tendancieuses
françois hollande est un incendie par le
compromis le projet de loi est maintenu
mais limitée et son examen au parlement
est repoussée après les élections
municipales
christiane taubira revoit sa copie et
présente une réforme a minima en conseil
des ministres puis à la presse
ce texte de loi lorsqu'il sera adopté en
application ce qui va compter c'est
l'efficacité
c'est pas noté lee new delhi qui a fait
mettre ça qui a fait un dessin pas ça
qui va compter mesure phare de la
réforme la contrainte pénale c'est une
peine que le condamné purge en dehors de
la prison il doit se soumettre à des
obligations comme réparer le préjudice
ou effectuer un travail d'intérêt
général
cette peine s'applique seulement aux
auteurs de délit puni de cinq ans de
prison maximum
c'est aux juges de choisir entre la
contrainte pénale et la prison présenté
en octobre 2013
ce texte va devoir attendre juin 2014
avant d'être débattu par les deux
assemblées
on
pour préparer la réforme les sénateurs
reçoivent experts et acteurs du monde
judiciaire
le contrôleur général des prisons est
l'une des premières personnalités
auditionnées
en 1975 il ya vingt-huit mille personnes
écrouées au 1er janvier
en 1985 dix ans plus tard quarante-cinq
mille en 1995 dix ans plus tard 53000 en
2005 59 milles et aujourd'hui 68 1600
plus de 68 mille détenus pour
aujourd'hui 57 mille places de prison la
france est victime d'une surpopulation
carcérale qui favorise la récidive je
crois qu'une bonne prise en charge au
sein de la prison facilite l'insertion
et par conséquent écarte les personnes
condamnées de la récidive et
corollairement je crois que de mauvaises
conditions d'existence en détention
celle qui méconnaissent la dignité des
personnes facilite la récidive le
meilleur instrument de prévention la
récidive que je connaisse c'est la
famille c'est dire que nos instruments à
nous les instruments étatiques ne
remplissent pas tout à fait le rôle ou
en tout cas n'occupe pas une place
centrale dans le fait qu'une personne va
acquitter la délinquance
les magistrats sont d'accord avec cette
analyse la plupart sont favorables à la
réforme
dans le bureau d'emilie gaudin juge
d'application des peines
les entretiens se succèdent en fait
c'est une dispute qui a mal tourné quand
vous avez commencé à vous disputez vous
y avez porté une gifle vous reconnaissez
vous dites c'est un geste approprié mais
que vous étiez énervée elle était
marquée l'avait un bleu au niveau de
l'oeil
vous avez six mois au dessus de la tête
pendant deux ans et vous avez deux
obligations principales qui sont vous
soumettre à des mesures de soins et
réparer les dommages causés par
l'infraction dans ce service les
magistrats suivent en majorité des
condamnés en milieu ouvert
cent soixante quinze mille personnes
purgent déjà aujourd'hui leur peine à
domicile
c'est trois fois plus que le nombre de
personnes derrière les barreaux s'ils ne
respectent pas leurs obligations c'est
le retour à la case prison pour cet
homme
il faut chercher activement du travail
et se soigner vous avez été condamné par
créteil le 27 mai 2011 à 4 ans dont 2
ans avec sursis mise à l'épreuve pour
des faits en lien avec les stupéfiants
ont transport détention offre aux
cessions et acquisitions dons autorisés
de stupéfiants
donc tous les mois vous avez un rendez
vous par mois en fait à l'hôpital henri
mondor au service des addictions
d'accord les peines en milieu ouvert
existe donc déjà alors que vient changer
la contrainte pénales envers l'idéologie
est très intéressante et c'est vrai que
c'est une avancée pour nous parce que ça
permet
d'accentuation suivi et donc comme le
disait vers la prison en soit ça peut
être une étape ça peut mettre un frein à
une délinquance aussi à une spirale
délinquante métier après quand ils
sortent de détention ils sont pas
suivies et bien effectivement ils vont
retourner dans leur quartier ils vont
retourner dans leur misère pour la
plupart ils n'auront pas de travail pas
de suivi et c'est très compliqué parce
que pour faire des démarches voilà quand
on a rien effectivement ma la
délinquance ça peut être une façon de
s'en sortir
al'inverse de ce qui existe aujourd'hui
par exemple avec le sursis avec mise à
l'épreuve qui est d'abord une peine
d'emprisonnement conditionnelle une
peine d'emprisonnement qui est prononcée
mais qui ne serait exécutée que si la
personne ne respecte pas des obligations
la contrainte pénale ll anvers ne fait
pas référence à l'emprisonnement c'est
une peine qui implique prioritairement
le suivi de la personne condamnée en
milieu libre avec le principe d'un suivi
soutenu renforcée mais les magistrats
restent sceptiques sur la limitation de
la contrainte pénale au délit de cinq
ans maximum
aujourd'hui déjà ils peuvent prononcer
un sursis pour tous les délits
même les plus graves le projet de loi
limite et soul influence de manuel valls
a déçu leurs attentes
certains députés socialistes vont aller
dans le sens des magistrats et propose
d'étendre la contrainte pénale à tous
les délits ces élus ont alors la
bénédiction de christiane taubira trop
contente de retrouver l'esprit initial
de la réforme mais éviter la prison
alors qu'on a commis un vol aggravé
serait alors possible et la droite agite
le chiffon rouge du laxisme avec la
contrainte pénal vous ouvrez grand les
portes et les fenêtres des prisons ces
dispositions de votre texte sont
disparates et je lâche le mot tout de
suite laxistes derrière cet amendement
se cassent la possibilité de ne plus
envoyer en prison
le gouvernement craint l'opinion
publique sur un sujet sensible
christiane taubira se fait recadrer par
françois hollande dans ce climat la
garde des sceaux s'incline à nouveau
elle renonce à soutenir l'amendement
étendant la contrainte pénale à tous les
délits le sénat à son tour se saisit du
texte la haute-assemblée n'entend pas se
faire dicter sa conduite par le
gouvernement le rapporteur proche de
christiane taubira n'a été reçu ni par
le premier ministre ni par le ministre
de l'intérieur et revendique son
indépendance
s'il avait bu
me rencontrer ils m'ont invité à
déjeuner c'est ce qui se fait d'habitude
et en général je refuse et là j'aurais
être acceptée en tant que rapporteur
jean pierre michel a été désigné par la
commission des lois du sénat pour
étudier le texte en profondeur il
souhaite aller plus loin encore que
l'assemblée nationale et rendre la
contrainte pénale obligatoire pour
certains délits la contrainte médaille
c'est très bien mais il faut en faire
une paye autonome
il faut qu'on sache que celle une vraie
peine donc j'ai voulu aller prudemment
et dire que pour une série de délits
limitativement énumérées qui sont des
petits délits sans intérêt aux personnes
sans violence bien sûr sans
discrimination pour ces délits la le
juge il a plus de peine de prison
encourue
jean-pierre michel ne laisse donc plus
le choix aux juges
même s'il se cantonne à une liste
restreinte de délits les moins graves
les vols simples et destructions
dégradations et détériorations sans
danger les délits de fuite usage de
stupéfiants l'occupation des halls
d'immeubles et les délits routiers
les condamnés n'encourait plus de peines
de prison le rapporteur se défend de
tout laxisme subir pendant plusieurs
mois plusieurs années les obligations
fortes baisses et aussi contraignantes
que de passer trois ou quatre ans en
prison un ça assez clair voilà surtout
pour un terrien de délinquants qui en
prison sous la coupe douce et qui
finalement se disent bon quand on s'en
tire en retournera d'où revient pour les
petites peines de moins de 6 mois en
allemagne par exemple la paix des
prisons est interdite
elle ne peut pas être prononcée pour en
allemagne je parle même pas de la
norvège ou la suède qui sont réputés
pour être très avant cette veine là
d'ailleurs
en norvège on vient d'annoncer qu'on
ferme des peines des places de prison
je souhaite comme se maintenait dans la
tête que healy a aujourd'hui 3 pen
délictuelle la peine d'emprisonnement
avec ou sans sursis la peine contre une
pénal et la sanction pécuniaire
mot pour mot jean pierre michel reprend
les termes utilisés par robert badinter
lors de son audition au sénat quelques
mois plus tôt du coup tout devient plus
clair sinon enfin clair la prison
l'approbation et en troisième lieu ce
que sont les peines pécuniaires cetera
l'ancien garde des sceaux est une figure
très écouté sur les questions de justice
il incite les sénateurs ses anciens
collègues à donner plus d'ambition au
texte le moment est venu de savoir ce
que voulait faire ou c'est la xxi ème
réforme en attendant les suivantes et
puis qui attendra son tour la prochaine
où cette fois ci en stop
j'évoquais le mot de consensus et tous
ensemble en examine ce qui peut être
fait pour les décennies à venir
le texte va dans la bonne direction il
ne va pas assez loin
c'est un bon texte inachevé
c'est pour ça que le sénat un rôle
particulier à jouer
il faut dire qu'au sénat le climat n'a
rien à voir avec celui de l'assemblée
nationale à droite comme à gauche
personne n'est favorable au tout
carcéral
nous croyons tous que les courtes peines
de prison sont inutiles et même plutôt
dhuisy crois que c'est à peu près tout
le monde partage ce diagnostic
un sénateur ump jean-rené lecerf a même
annoncé son soutien à la réforme dans un
journal de gauche la ministre de la
justice rend hommage à ses prises de
position venu de la droite
ce qui est important ce n'est pas de
vitupérer ça n'est pas d'avoir des
postures ce n'est pas de transformer des
textes de lois en caricature ce qui est
important c'est ce que fait souvent
l'opposition ici au sénat à savoir
travailler sur le fond du texte exprimé
des désaccords constaté peut-être
dhainaut conciliation mais travailler
sur le fond du texte parce que ce sont
des maisons où l'on doit faire du droit
mais une critique est partagé par tous
les groupes politiques
le manque de moyens mais nous savons
d'avant ce que les moyens seront
insuffisants la grande majorité des
membres des deux assemblées sont en
faveur d'une baisse des dépenses
publiques
elle va se réaliser donc si nous votons
en regardant une fois de plus que le
souhaitable
un texte dont les moyens ne seront pas
présents
nous organisons l'échec d'hz avance la
contrainte pénale demande des moyens
supplémentaires et les acteurs de
terrain le savent
ça implique des moyens qui seront
énormes
ça viendra il faut déconseiller il faut
des juges il faut des structures il faut
un travail alors que déjà les gens qui
sont pas qu on a même du mal à trouver
un travail
donc ce avec la conteuse bnl ça va venir
s'ajouter à tous les suivis qu'on a déjà
et oui ça va peut-être être dur à être
mis en place selon les moyens qui nous
seront accordés pour rassurer ses
troupes le ministère de la justice
prévoit un effort sans précédent
les conseillers pénitentiaires
d'insertion et de probation chargés au
quotidien du suivi des condamnés doivent
passer de 4000 à 5000 d'ici 2017 une
augmentation des effectifs qui paraît
dérisoire face à la masse de travail à
venir la mise en place de la contrainte
vénale signifierait entre vimy les vingt
mille dossiers supplémentaires par an
non là on pourra pas faire face non ou
alors ce sera de la gestion quasi
administrative
c'est à dire qu'après à ce moment là on
convoque neuf personnes dans la journée
et on les voit toutes les demi-heures et
voilà pour pour relancer les obligations
pour qu'ils nous amènent leur leurs
justificatifs mais ce sera pas du
travail de fond quoi
marie-france fourni et suis plus d'une
centaine de dossiers à la fois parmi eux
de nombreux aménagements de peine des
personnes dont elle connaît le parcours
personnel et professionnel pour les
aider à se réinsérer
c'est le cas de wayne condamné à
plusieurs reprises pour conduite en état
d'ivresse
alors on fait un petit bilan aujourd'hui
parce qu'on est presque un an là alors
qu'est-ce que là où on année ou alors à
ce jour sur le plan professionnel
le cdi qui signé depuis le 1er mars
marcel mauss d'accord depuis un an gwan
termine sa peine en dehors du milieu
carcéral sur sept dernières années
d'incarcération
vous n'êtes plus en détention mais vous
êtes sur le placement extérieur donc qui
vous permet de travailler votre projet
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle plutôt
que de rester incarcéré jusqu'à la fin
où là je pense que sur la dernière année
vous auriez jamais obtenu ce que vous
avez obtenu l'accord puisse ressortir
une panne sèche en voilà donc avec les
mains sûrement dû laisser préparer la
sortie pour éviter de recommencer
c'est l'objectif de ce suivi très étroit
j'avais un suivi médical donc au
rendez-vous à peu près tous les quinze
jours avec une infirmière des docteurs
et psychologues puisse m'aider marche du
travail plus l'accompagnement avec moi
mon petit parce que j'avais
l'autorisation de le recevoir donc dans
mon appartement et et b il fallait que
je m'en sorte
et même quand il en aura fini wen pourra
toujours s'appuyer sur sa conseillère
marie france fournier continuent souvent
à suivre les ex-détenus malgré les
dossiers qui s'accumulent des magistrats
sont très sévères vis-à-vis de la
contrainte pénale version sénat la
rendre obligatoire pour certains délits
comme le demande le rapporteur
jean-pierre michel remettent en cause
leur façon de travailler
la contrainte pénale en elle même n'est
toujours pas opposé la difficulté c'est
quand elle devient la peine unique
encourus pour tel ou tel type de délit
par exemple pour le vol c'est ce qui est
prévu dans ce cas là on ne peut rien
prononcé d'autres peu importe qu'il y
ait les moyens ou non de prendre en
charge ces contraintes pénale peu
importe que la contrainte pénales soient
adaptés ou non à la personne qui va être
condamné c'est surtout ça qui nous pose
problème
retour au sénat pour le début de
l'examen de la réforme de christiane
taubira
la presse annonce un débat explosif
la contrainte pénale obligatoire a mis
le feu aux poudres matignon en rage mais
jean-pierre michel assume je vais dans
la ligne de ce qu'est la ligne de la
gauche
alors évidemment si on me dit
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus la gauche et
la ligne du gouvernement
ça c'est autre chose mais comme le
disent franchement alors on me dit que
je suis provocateur bon j'ai pas
provocateur du tout que je suis
responsable c'est pas irresponsable du
tout ce après midi j'ai vu que j'étais
incontrôlable c'est aussi une épithète
qui n'est pas vraiment non ce que je
peux dire c'est que mais ça c'est le cas
de tous les sénateurs c'est que je suis
moins sensibles ou perméable aux
pressions d'où qu'elles viennent que de
lait un député qui a été lui après une
action présidentielle et qui doit tout
l'élection présidentielle voilà ça c'est
vrai théâtral dans les couloirs la garde
des sceaux change de ton à la tribune
elle parle avec modération et pédagogie
et ne veut pas enflammé le débat
la peine doit servir à punir l'exécution
de la peine doit préparer à la
réinsertion
c'est valable pour les longs peine qui
peut ni sur les crimes ça l'est aussi
pour les courtes peines qui punissent
les délits et je rappelle que le texte
sur lequel nous travaillons ne concerne
que les délits vous avez la conviction
erronée que l'on a car sert trop en
france que la prison serait l'école du
crime est cassée motif il faut prendre
des dispositions pour empêcher le
recours à l'emprisonnement à tout prix
décidément l'antisarkozysme demeure le
principal moteur de la majorité comme en
atteste
comme en attestent les dangereuses
amendement adopté en commission des lois
de notre assemblée
alors moi aussi j'ai lu les titres de ce
journal du matin qui a dénoncé sur six
ou sept colonnes la gauche anti prison
ce titre est une insulte et qu'une
imposture je le dénonce
nous ne sommes pas contre la prison nous
pensons que la prison est nécessaire
mais il n'est pas possible que la seule
paix
elle soit la prison comment espérer
réinsérer dans la société
ce qu'on aura privé pendant des aînés de
toute dignité
je pense et j'espère et je croyais donc
que sur ces questions si difficile mais
si essentiel nous pourrions nous
retrouver de droite de gauche du centre
ou d'ailleurs
côte à côte et non frontalement opposé
deuxième jour de débats au sénat les
sénateurs commencent par abolir un
symbole des années sarkozy
les peines minimales pour les
récidivistes les fameuses peines
planchers si l'on en croit effectivement
le gouvernement et la majorité les
peines planchers n'ont eu aucun impact
sur la prévention de la récidive et ont
uniquement aggraver la surpopulation
carcérale
or il n'en est rien elle de législateur
voulait lutter contre la récidive est en
réalité il a mis en place un dispositif
qui en augmentant considérablement la
population carcérale 35 % d'augmentation
en disant à contrecarrer tout ce qui
pouvait être fait dans les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
lutter justement contre la récidive
cette suppression voulue par le
gouvernement et adoptée par tous les
groupes de gauche c'est une formalité
mais voilà que les sénateurs aborde le
coeur du débat la contrainte pénale
obligatoire pour certains délits dans la
matinée jean pierre michel a renoncé à
inscrire le vol dans sa liste pour mieux
faire passer son amendement
l'idée c'était la tenthrède pénale est
une peine autonome qui se substitue à la
peine d'emprisonnement
voilà et que en matière délictuelle on
doit être sur un triptyque la prison la
contrainte pénal les peines pécuniaires
pour la garde des sceaux ce changement
est prématurée
la contrainte pénale dans la version
initiale est suffisamment fortes telles
que c'est con sus une sanction lourde ça
dure et c'est de six mois à cinq ans
c'est une sanction lourde
les obligations champ plus large que ce
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui dans le sursis
avec mise à l'épreuve
les interdictions pareillement donc là
la contrainte pénale est une est une
vraie peine scène surprenante la garde
des sceaux est soutenu par la droite qui
elle aussi refuse de rendre la
contrainte pénale obligatoire pour
certains délits le ministre moi je une
fois n'est pas coutume je volerais bien
à votre secours car à l'instant de nom
c'est sérieux à l'instant où nous
parlons je ne sais pas où est la vraie
contrainte pénale cet article supprime
la peine de référence actuellement en
vigueur qui est l'emprisonnement et
c'est pas nouveau qui est de longue date
l'emprisonnement qui pour toute la
population et la peine de référence pour
imposer dans un certain nombre de cas la
contrainte pénale nous savons très bien
que pour les délits qui a énuméré notre
rapporteur le plus souvent si prison il
y a
où il y avait eu il y aurait ce serait
des courtes peines et que les courtes
peines de prison ont des tas de
conséquences d'abord on sait que c'est
par rapport aux courtes peines qui a le
moins d'aménagement le moins de
préparation de la sortie
et puis toutes les voix de gauche se
rassemble et adopte la contrainte pénale
obligatoire qui est pour
merci mes chers collègues et le reste du
débat se poursuit ainsi le sénat suis
point par point les préconisations du
rapporteur proche de christiane taubira
souvent contre l'avis officiel du
gouvernement qui votent le texte qui est
pour et qui est contre
pour tout vous remercie le texte est
donc adopté
l'important c'est pas de savoir si le
gouvernement le sénat sur un point en
particulier ou sur une demi phrase était
en désaccord ou en accord c'est pas ça
l'important
ce qui compte c'est qu'elle est la
qualité de ce texte quelle est la
solidité des mesures et quels résultats
peut en attendre officiellement désavoué
par les sénateurs de gauche
la ministre joue un double jeu faire
elle été personnellement très favorable
à toutes les modifications adoptées par
le sénat
elle est dans un gouvernement et en ce
gouvernement il ya eu des arbitrages
donc les loyal avec le gouvernement et
elle défend la position du gouvernement
dont éléments et j'ai le sentiment que
nous nous défendons l'esprit de la loi
taubira
voilà c'est simple et je vous le rend
bien
dans la buvette des sénateurs la
ministre est d'ailleurs accueillie par
les principaux orateurs de la gauche
même s'ils ont très souvent voté contre
sa position officielle ces derniers
jours c'est bien avec eux qu'elle fait
l'adoption du texte
je
une quinzaine de jours plus tard à
l'assemblée nationale sept sénateurs et
sept députés se réunissent en commission
mixte paritaire
leur objectif se mettre d'accord sur un
texte de compromis
en réalité cela fait une semaine que les
tractations ont lieu non pas entre les
parlementaires mais avec le gouvernement
la réunion se termine rapidement
la commission mixte paritaire a réussi
par un accord entre l'assemblée et le
sénat
et je peux dire que beaucoup des
propositions du sénat ont bien sûr été
prise en compte pas tout c'est
évidemment c'est du donnant donnant et
chacun a fait un pas vers l'autre
le président de la commission des lois
se félicite mais la contrainte pénale
version sénat a été balayée c'est
l'assemblée qui l'a emporté
le juge aura le choix entre la prison et
la contrainte pénale qui se limite aux
délits passibles de cinq ans de prison
et en 2017 cette nouvelle peine sera
étendue à tous les délits
à l'autre bout de la france l'école de
l'administration pénitentiaire n'a pas
attendu le parlement pour lancer la
réforme les effectifs supplémentaires
promis par le ministère seront formés
dès septembre
trois cent soixante dix conseillers
d'insertion et de probation au lieu des
130 habituels les futurs artisans au
quotidien de la contrainte pénale vous
avez donné votre ticket voile et dormir